President Trump says the federal
government will spare no expense in
dealing with Florence he tweeted this
this morning we got a pluses for our
recent hurricane work in Texas in
Florida and did an unappreciated great
job in Puerto Rico he added we are ready
for the big one that is coming now part
of that tweet answers critics of the
government government's hurricane
response in Puerto Rico major Garrett is
at the White House with more on that
major good morning good morning
president Trump reviewed hurricane
preparations here yesterday in advance
of this massive storm but when asked
about the federal hurricane response in
Puerto Rico last year he deemed it quote
incredibly successful well that prompted
the mayor of San Juan Puerto Rico
to accuse the President on Twitter of
trivializing the loss of life there and
ignoring long-standing but still
unfulfilled requests from the island for
more federal assistance it's
tremendously big and tremendously wet
President Trump declared states of
emergency in the Carolinas and Virginia
clearing the way for immediate federal
assistance part of a multi-layered
effort to evacuate and brace for
hurricane Florence
I think the Puerto Rico was an
incredible unsung success but a killer
storm last year Hurricane Maria
triggered renewed scrutiny the president
praised the federal response in the face
of fresh reports that nearly three
thousand died and months passed before
electricity was restored to populated
areas of Puerto Rico I actually think it
was one of the best jobs that's ever
been done with respect to what this is
all about the Puerto Rican government
originally said 64 people died in the
storm but recently conceded that number
vastly underestimated the death toll the
president said the islands power woes
were known before Maria hit their
electric grid of their electric
generating plan was dead before the
storms ever hit it was in very bad shape
that was in bankruptcy had no money it
was largely you know was largely closed
and we have some photos we want to show
you they began circulating on social
media yesterday and show what appear to
be millions of water bottles on an
airport runway and save up order Rico
now federal emergency officials told CBS
News yesterday they delivered those
bottles of water turn them over to the
central government in Puerto Rico but
John the federal officials told us they
have no idea what became of the bottles
after the delivery major thank you